Und ich habe mir vorgenommen, immer nach einer halben Stunde nach einem What the fuck Moment des Jahres zu fragen. Und da haben wir jetzt einen Anrufer, der das machen kann, das ist der André. Und dem André muss ich vorher mal was anderes fragen. Hallo André. Du bist ja aus dem Friedrichshain. Das ist ja quasi Minuten von hier entfernt, weil wir sind ja heute live aus dem Fräulein Fritz. Warum bist du nicht einfach vorbeigekommen?
Ja, ich habe es zu spät festgestellt, dass es da ist. Und ich sagte es vor kurzem auch über meine Matterhausaufgaben.
Ist ja auch kalt draußen. Ich würde ja auch nicht rausgehen wollen.
Du kannst doch jetzt nicht demotivieren, Mann.
Das schon, also.
Also, ich könnte den Spaziergang vertragen, ja, aber gut, also, aber Matterhausaufgaben lassen wir gelten.
Ja, das muss das muss sein für morgen.
Du hast einen WTF Moment mitgebracht. Was war der für dich?
Ja, der WTF Moment für mich war eigentlich dieses Jahr. Das war irgendwann im Sommer, kurz vor der Sommerpause, dass der Bundestrojaner als Trojaner durchgewinkt wurde. Ich glaube, das war bei der Autobahn Privatisierung oder bei der Autobahn Maut für PKWs. Da war der mit als Einhang dabei und kaum einer hat den gelesen. Der Gesetzesvorschlag ging durch und damit auch der Bundestrojaner. Das hat mich dermaßen angekotzt.
Habt ihr das noch verschirmen?
Ich glaube, dazu hatten wir noch eine PM rausgebracht, wo wir uns deutlichst empört haben.
Es fehlen einfach ein paar Polen im Agrarausschuss bei uns. Polen im Agrarausschuss. Auf EU-Ebene ist das Ding, glaube ich, mal gestoppt worden, weil die polnische Delegation im Agrarausschuss, wo es nachts durchgewunken werden sollte, gesagt hat, was hat das mit Agrarpolitik zu tun?
Nee.
Und jetzt haben wir hier so richtige Bundesprojekte?
Ja, schon.
Sie nennen es ja Quellen-TKÜ.
Aber André, anders gesagt, warum stört sich das denn? Warum war das ein What the fuck Moment? Hast du etwa etwas zu verbergen? Oder was hast du gegen den Bundestrojaner?
Ja klar hab ich was zu verbergen. Wer hat nichts zu verbergen? Ich hab meine Privatsphäre zu verbergen.
Hat dich das denn dazu geführt, dass du dieses Jahr dann irgendwie auch aufgestanden bist und aktiv geworden bist? Oder hat es dich sozusagen so gelähmt, dass du gesagt hast, was? Ich mach jetzt zu, du hast nur noch Mathe-Hausaufgaben.
Nein, ich wollte das eigentlich tun, aber ich hatte keinen gefunden und dann ging es dann auch halt zum Semesterarbeiten. Also da war ich dann noch nicht mal in Deutschland.
Oh, gleich ausreisen. Wenn der Bundesrat da kommt, da reisen wir gleich auf.
Wenn ich fertig bin, ja definitiv.
Wohin soll es dann gehen?
Das weiß ich noch nicht, wahrscheinlich ESA oder NASA.
Auch nicht schlecht.
Ich glaube die überwachen noch nicht so viel im Weltraum. Also ist das nicht die ganz gute Flugflugmöglichkeit von diesen Leuten.
Also sagen wir so, das was ich da machen möchte, hat ja auch nichts mit Überwachen zu tun. Das sind Terraforming-Projekte.
Aber man baut sich dann eine neue Erde und kann diese hier verlassen?
Ich will gerade sagen, ich finde das schon, ich finde es verständlicher als Reaktion, aber auch ein bisschen krasser zu sagen. Also nicht nur in Deutschland verlassen, sondern gleich die ganze Erde und dann einfach einen neuen Planeten formen, den dann möglicherweise unüberwachen. Aber sagt mal, liebe Expertinnen und Experten, warte, wir haben gar keine Experten, das ist auch so ein Problem, das sollten wir 2018 mal ändern. Es gab ja auch was so Überwachung von staatlicher Seite und Cyber-Cyber angeht. Noch ein anderes Thema, was wir da mal vorgekommen sind, nämlich CITES. Hast du das auch verfolgt, André? Das lassen wir uns jetzt erklären, was war CITES?
Die Zentrale Stelle für Informationstechnik im Sicherheitsbereich.
Das klingt voll gut, ne?
Das hast du abgelesen, oder?
Okay, dann lassen wir uns jetzt mal erklären. André, dir auf jeden Fall vielen Dank schon mal für deinen What the fuck Moment.
Ja wartet mal, dann komm ich doch noch vorbei.
Fräulein Fritz ist in der Falkensteinstraße am Schlesischen Tor.
Am Schlesischen Tor, aber das ist ja doch ein bisschen weiter weg.
Na komm on, jetzt einmal übern Fluss, in der Baumhausbar, also neben der Baumhausbar.
Hoxig in ihrem 10-Biss-Hogzug da.
Genau. Nicht, dass sie vorhin gerade irgendwie komplett lahmgelegt gewesen wäre, aber... Also André, wenn du willst, komm noch vorbei, wir würden uns freuen. So, CITES, was war das? Warum haben wir das und was erwartet uns da?
CITES, Cyber.
Ja, das ist eigentlich so ein tolles Ober-Cyber-Ministerium, das, glaube ich, sie haben gar nicht so genau gesagt, was es darf. Es darf nur mit allen zusammenarbeiten und darf so miniprinzipiell alles. Und man kann nicht genau sagen, was sie tun, aber sie dürfen trotzdem einfach mal alles machen.
Also was sie halt erkannt haben, sie da oben, TM, ist Spezialisten, die gewisse Aufgabe übernehmen können, die halt im Zusammenhang mit, ich möchte mal gerade gucken, was in diesen Daten drin steht, was in diesem Handy drin ist, wie auch immer. Die gibt es nur sehr beschränkt. Und die Lösung, die sie dann hatten, war, wir bauen eine zentrale Stelle, deswegen auch zentrale Stelle für Informationssicherheit im Sicherheitsbereich. Und das ist quasi ein Dienstleister für alle anderen Behörden im Sicherheitsbereich und löst zentral die Probleme, wo sonst jede einzelne Behörde einzelne Leute für brauchen würde.
Ein Cyberdienstleister, weil das sind dann, die die Ahnung von diesem ganzen Computerkram haben.
Dazu brauchen die auch jede Menge Fachleute, da gab es auch eine große Stellenausschreibung.
Genau, die haben so alles von ITlern, was es so gibt, aus allen möglichen Bereichen mal angefragt. Und dadurch, dass sie halt mit allen, dass sie so ein bisschen übergreifend sind, haben sie halt nicht wirklich so eine gewisse Einschränkung, soweit ich das lesen konnte, dass sie halt sagen, ihr dürft euch nur darum kümmern oder nur um Landessache oder Bundessache oder folgende Angelegenheiten, sondern eigentlich so mit, wenn ein Computer involviert ist, dürft ihr euch involvieren.
Okay, und diese Fachleute, haben die sich jetzt auch da zahlreich beworben? Weiß man das, ob es die deutsche innere Hacker-Armee schon gibt?
Also sie haben ja alles gegeben. Sie haben das in München angesiedelt. Sie haben das an der Bundeswehr-Uni angesiedelt. Also zumindest ist es da in derselben Location. Dann gab es aber, und das war auch eine unserer Nerd-News erst vor gar nicht so langer Zeit, ich glaube letztendlich vor letztem Monat, dass die ZITES-Eröffnung dann doch irgendwie abgesagt werden musste. Und offiziell war der Minister krank oder irgendwie sowas. Aber es verlautbarte, dass es möglicherweise auch etwas damit zu tun haben könnte, dass von den 120 Planstellen zu diesem Zeitpunkt leider nur 17 besetzt werden konnten.
Aber dann haben sie es outgesourced und einen Rahmenvertrag mit dem Chaos Computer Club abgeschlossen.
Das ist dann die Sorrentis Cyberwehr.
Wir hatten noch diese Krisen-Nummer von Demisier, die er haben wollte, und das haben wir dann damit reingepackt.
Und beim IT-Gipfel hat er irgendwie sowas gemacht.
Was ist nochmal langsam? Was? Krisen-Nummer? Chaos Computer Club? Was bitte?
Na, der Herr Demisier hat sich ja mal gewünscht, dass er eine Krisen-Nummer hat, dass wenn es eine Computer-Krise in Deutschland gibt, dann kann man da anrufen. Und dann gehen die Experten vom Chaos Computer Club dran und retten das Land.
Was hat der gesagt?
Ja, auf einer Bühne.
Aber ich mein, mal abgesehen davon, dass die Idee schon okay ist, aber der Imagewandel, den der Chaos Computer Club sozusagen durchgemacht hat, ist schon auch beachtlich, oder? Also ich mein, es war schon so, dass es Zeiten gab, wo der Chaos Computer Club eher so, das sind die komischen Leute, die auch eigentlich eher so Terroristen sind.
Ich bin mir im Nachhinein nicht sicher, ob das damals eine gute Idee war, dann doch einen EV zu gründen, nicht die Terrororganisation.
Also wir sind ein EV, weil man uns damals nahegelegt hat. Also wenn ihr euch nicht in kontrollierbare Strukturen begebt, dann könnten wir ja auf die Idee kommen, dass ihr möglicherweise eine Terrororganisation seid. Und seitdem gibt es den EV.
Okay, was ich eigentlich sagen wollte ist, der Imagewandel des Chaos Computer Clubs ist doch ganz okay eigentlich, oder nicht?
Ist okay, aber auf der anderen Seite sehen wir uns halt nicht als Dienstleister. Und das ist auch ganz, ganz, ganz fatal.
Natürlich, aber auf dieser Ebene, dass du sagen, ein Politiker, der wird es sicherlich, also man weiß es nicht genau, aber ich vermute, er hat das nicht ganz so ernst gemacht.
Am Ende holen die sich die Mitgliedsdaten von CCC und dann kommen die Feldjäger und holen die Leute ab und sagen, wir haben hier einen Cyberfall und wir müssen jetzt alle CCCler hier in einen Acker drücken.
Das war ja im Prinzip die erste Eskalationsstufe, das war zeitlich vor dem Cyberwehrvorschlag, wo es dann hieß, wir ziehen alle Sicherheits- also alle Leute, die-
Es gab tatsächlich die Idee in der Zwangsverpflichtung, das habe ich nicht mitbekommen.
Nee, freiwillig. Also Firmen sollten freiwillig ihre Experten dem Land zur Verfügung stellen im Fall einer Cyberkrise.
Wow.
Dafür solltest du eine Freistellung vom Arbeitsvertrag und so geben und dann machst du Cyberabwehr.
Das klingt gut. Freut ihr euch schon?
Eigentlich nicht.
Wieso? Weil nein. Aber mal andersherum gefragt. Also als Mann für alle theoretischen Situationen kann man sich ja schon vorstellen, also gab es hier irgendwie einen Stromausfall dieses Jahr, der auf Hackdings irgendwie zu tun hatte?
Heizungsausfälle gab es wegen dem DINALOFT SERVICE, aber Stromausfall glaube ich, weiß ich jetzt nicht.
Nein, es gab dieses Ding, es gab diese Ransomware, die auch Krankenkrankhaus irgendwie da Namen gelegt hat.
Das britische Gesundheitssystem und die dort angeschlossenen.
Genau, das war ja so. Das kann man sich ja durchaus auch noch eine Nummer größer vorstellen. Also nicht sozusagen Krankenhäuser, sondern alle Krankenhäuser.
Ja, aber in dem Fall wäre es halt mal interessant zu sehen, wie sie sowas überhaupt koordinieren wollen und was sie sich davon versprechen.
Aber das finde ich schon sehr selbstherrlich, sich als Hacker hinzusetzen, so ja die Krankenhäuser sind alle offline, jetzt gucken wir mal, wie ihr das koordiniert.
Das Ding ist ja nicht, dass wir seit Jahren vor genau den Gefahren, die ignoriert werden, warnen. Also wir warnen ja vor dieser grenzenlosen und unkonkretierten Vernetzung und davor, dass du den AKW 25.000 Remotezugänge für die Wartungsfirmen hast.
Ja schon, aber wenn es jetzt passieren würde, würde der euch dann hinsetzen und sagen, so nö, machen wir nicht. Wir haben es euch ja gesagt, für den Told you so Tanz auf der Asche.
Problem ist, du kannst da gar nicht viel machen. Du kannst die Sachen runterfahren, ausschalten und dann kann man mal sehen.
Wir hatten dieses Jahr am Chaosradio auch eine Sendung über, ich weiß gar nicht mehr, wie der Fachbegriff hieß, aber Leute, die sich professionell damit beschäftigen, was man tut, wenn Dinge passiert sind im eigenen Netzwerk. Und da ist schon ein bisschen Fachkompetenz da.
Durchaus, aber die machen halt auch erst mal nichts anderes, als wenn es zu spät ist, versuchen sie...
Ich fühle einen ausweichenden Antwort auf meine Frage.
Was machst du als Incident Response? Als Incident Response machst du Geräte vom Netz trennen, dafür sorgen, dass der Angrafer nicht weitermachen kann, schaltest die Sachen runter und fängst mit einem manuellen Notbetrieb an.
Na ja, genau, aber dazu brauchst du halt Leute, die das machen. Dann wäre die Frage, ist es nicht denkbar, also ist es nicht grundsätzlich eine gute Idee, dass man sagt, wenn sowas passiert, dann zieht man einfach alle Leute zusammen die Ahnung haben und versucht das dann zu nennen.
Du unterstellst aber, dass kriminelles Handeln das gleiche ist wie die Naturkatastrophe.
Ich unterstelle, dass es dieselben Auswirkungen hat und dass man dann als Mensch, der helfen kann, vielleicht eine moralische Verpflichtung hat, auch diese Hälfte zu geben.
Gehen wir davon aus, dass es wirklich ein großflächiger IT-Angriff ist und da sind jetzt irgendwelche Kraftwerker ausgefallen.
Ein Beispiel.
Die CCC Leute, wenn du die jetzt als IT-Experten siehst, haben keine Ahnung, wie man ein Kraftwerk manuell wieder hochfährt. Dafür gibt es dann Experten bei einem Kraftwerksbetreiber. Das Problem ist, dass du ohne IT-Unterstützung halt noch handlungsfähig sein musst. Und das kann man dann auch nicht mal eben in so einer Niveau wieder herstellen. Da musst du halt wirklich Handbetrieb machen und nach und nach die Sachen wieder ins Netz bringen und hochfahren. Da nützt es aber nichts, wenn jemand von außen kommt, der das System überhaupt nicht kennt.
Man kann auch jetzt nicht, natürlich kann es jetzt beliebig Fälle sozusagen konstruieren, wo man sagt, naja, da muss es aber auch, da muss es aber auch irgendwie analog gehen sozusagen. Aber es ist doch, es ist doch genauso gut denkbar, dass halt so ein Ding passiert, wo man sagt, das würde halt schon helfen.
Nee, eigentlich nicht. Also wenn eine Krankenhaus-IT kaputt ist, dann musst du halt dafür sorgen, dass du ohne IT die Leute operierst und stabilisierst. Da gibt es andere Prioritäten, als das IT-System wieder hochzufahren.
Na ob das wirklich so ist, falls gerade ein Krankenhaus-IT-Lehrer zuhört, gerne anrufen. 0331 77 97 110. Bevor wir uns jetzt ganz in der Katastrophe verlieren, wollten wir, haben wir vorhin angekündigt, über ein anderes Thema sprechen, nämlich, ihr habt so kurz angedeutet, dass ihr nicht so ganz okay findet oder verwunderlich, dass sich Leute viel Technik ins Haus stellt, die ihnen zuhört. Ja, gerade das Internet of Things, Alexa's, Google Homes und Apple. Ach nee, Apple hat sein Produkt jetzt nochmal zurückgezogen, weil es doch nicht so geil war.
Siri? War das Siri?
Apple hat jetzt auch so einen Home-Lautsprecher mit Sprachsteuerungs-Dings irgendwie an den Start gebracht. Dann war das so, naja, lieber doch nicht, wir müssen das nochmal schön machen oder wie auch immer.
Also es ist halt interessant zu beobachten, wie schnell Widerstand bei Leuten einbricht, sobald ein gewisses Komfortversprechen da ist.
Das hat dann auch nicht mal funktioniert.
Es funktioniert so lange, bis jemand im Fernsehen Alexa sagt.
Ja, oder du hast dann dieses Versprechen mit dem Smart Home und der LED-Lampe, die dann irgendwie gestaltet wird und dann stellst du fest, ich sage, mach das Licht an und es dauert drei Sekunden oder fünf oder zehn, bis das Licht mal reagiert, weil das halt durchs Internet muss. Oder der Server vom Dienstleister ist weg und dann geht das Licht gar nicht mehr.
Was wir jetzt unlängst hatten, also gerade letztes Wochenende.
Von vorne.
Also du kannst dir Smart Home Komponenten kaufen und anstatt dass die, wie man sich das so einfach vorstellt, einfach bei dir lokal im Haushalt, sich untereinander unterhalten, laufen die aus, was weiß ich für Gründen, immer über den Server des Herstellers. Das bedeutet aber auch, dass wenn der Server oder dies war, war es ja nie einer. Es ist ja schon ein bisschen aufwendiger und nicht so leicht kaputt zu machen. Das wäre zumindest die Hoffnung, aber offensichtlich ist es passiert, dass die Infrastruktur dieses Herstellers komplett runtergefahren ist über das Wochenende.
Also es gab da ein Softwareupdate und dann konnten die nicht mehr miteinander reden.
Gab es dann noch eine Möglichkeit, die Lampe einfach ein- und auszuschalten?
Teilweise.
Sehr gut. Aber zurück zu diesem Alexa-Ding. Was ich ja ganz spannend finde, ist, da stehen jetzt in den Wohnungen Dinge rum, die hören ständig zu.
Genau, das machen sich ja auch viele nicht klar. Letztendlich hören die stets und immer zu, dass sie angeblich nur nach einem Activation-Wort, also nach einem Wort der Aktivierung irgendwie Alexa oder sonst irgendwas, tatsächlich anfangen erst, Sachen zur Interprestation in die Cloud zu schicken, heißt ja nicht, dass man, wenn man sich irgendeine Malware einfängt oder so, dass das Ding nicht tatsächlich dann permanent irgendwas wegschicken könnte oder so. Alleine die Tatsache.
Dass da eine mit dem Internet verbundenes Mikrofon in deinem Wohnzimmer und in deinem Schlafzimmer steht. Hier im RSC krapacht gerade jemand den schönen Spruch, wo smart draufsteht, steckt Überwachung drin. Der stimmt halt leider sehr. Also alles, was Sprachsteuerung macht, arbeitet momentan so, dass diese Sprachbefehle eben nicht auf dem Gerät lokal ausgewertet werden und erkannt werden, sondern die Audioschnipsel werden an einen Server geschickt, irgendwo im Internet, der analysiert. Und teilweise hören sich auch Menschen das danach noch mal an, um zu gucken, ob das richtig analysiert wurde.
Na, das ist eigentlich ein bisschen schade, weil wenn man so zurück überlegt, mal 10, 15 Jahre, da gab es irgendwie, was war das, ein Nokia 6310, glaube ich, und da konnte man schon mit Sprachsteuerung Leute anrufen.
Ja, oder bei IBM gab es...
Und das haben die alles auf einem ollen Telefon von vor 15 Jahren gemacht. Und da frage ich mich ein bisschen mit so, da steckt doch viel mehr CPU-Leistungen, also viel mehr Leistungen an Rechenleistungen, so ein kleiner Alexa-Ding. Und da kann man eigentlich viele, viele Befehle dort abfrühstücken, in wahrscheinlich genauso schnell wie das Internet ist, bis man da irgendwie einmal Daten zu einem großen in die Cloud schiebt und zurück.
Aber haltet ihr das wirklich für komplett ausgedacht? Was jetzt genau? Also ja, die Datentour zu bedenken, so kann ich nachvollziehen, und ich habe die selber auch. Aber haltet ihr komplett ausgedacht, dass man sagt, es ist schon unter dem technischen Gesichtspunkt einfach praktischer, das Ding irgendwie zentral zu machen, weil man dann die Systeme besser trainieren kann, weil man dann irgendwie besser werden kann, und weil man das sozusagen nicht lokal macht. Und dann einfach, also das lokal ist ja, dann stellt man das System dahin, dann muss es funktionieren, und dann macht man das nächste irgendwie.
Ich finde die Diskussion schwierig, weil sie im Moment rein theoretisch ist. Weil es gibt im Moment kein Projekt, das, oder es gab, komme ich jetzt gleich drauf, kein Projekt, das es anders gemacht hätte. Und das schickt sich jetzt Mozilla an zu ändern. Die haben das Projekt, ich glaube, Common Voice heißt es, gestartet. Das versucht eben genau das, dass die Sachen erst mal möglichst lange auf dem eigenen PC oder dem eigenen Handy stattfinden, was Spracherkennung angeht, und dass man dann quasi möglichst spät erst auf die Cloud zurückgreift, was zumindest datenschutzrechtlich deutlich entspannter sein könnte, je nachdem, wie sich dieses Projekt entwickelt. Und da wird man dann sehen, wie gut solche Systeme sind, obwohl sie möglicherweise nicht deine kompletten Sprachschnipsel in die Cloud transportieren. Die Cloud oder überhaupt dieses VoiceProjekt könnte ja auch durchaus von Dingen lernen, die jetzt nicht direkt die Sprachschnipsel übertragen.
Nämlich?
In dem Meta-Informationen, die eben nicht genau die Sprache wiedergeben, analysiert werden.
Das finde ich, das ist ja auch mal eine spannende Frage, die... Also das habe ich ganz oft. Bei mir ist der Beef, den ich immer mit Messenger habe. Es gibt ja Messenger, die sagen so, ja, also wir übertragen deine Kontaktdaten, aber wir machen das in einer total anonymisierten Form. Da geht es dann gar nicht so. Das selbe stelle ich mir auch bei diesen Sprachdingen. Würde ich mir auch fragen. Also ob ich mir jetzt ein Ding hinstelle, das meine Sprachschnitzel überträgt, oder ein Ding hinstelle, das überträgt Sachen, aber verspricht, dass das andere Sachen sind. Für mich als normaler Nutzer ist das ja überhaupt nicht kontrollierbar. Ich will ja entweder ein Ding haben, das mit Netz funktioniert oder ohne. Und ich möchte halt am liebsten haben, wo ich so ein Hardware-Schalter habe, wo ich sage, so Netz aus. Aber das ist illusorisch.
Ja, es gibt wenige Systeme, die sind noch fern von, na ja doch, sie sind benutzerfreundlich, aber es ist halt richtig viel Aufwand, das hinzubekommen. Zum Beispiel so ein Smart Home kann man sich auch komplett offline bauen. Das geht dann vielleicht nicht per Sprachsteuerung, oder kannst du unten von dem Display an der Tür jede einzelne Lampe im Haus schalten. Und das geht auch schon länger.
Das ist halt die bewährte Technik, die es schon immer gab. E-B, InstaBus, was es da so gab. Das ist halt nicht mit dem Internet verbunden.
Genau, das tut aber genau so, bis auf das irgendwie die Sprachsteuerung fehlt. Aber dann gibt es jetzt wieder neue Hausautomatisierungslösungen, wo dann alles über einen Server läuft. Wo es dann heißt, wenn der Hersteller tops geht, hast du worst case ein Haus mit ganz vielen Schaltern, was du nicht mehr bedienen kannst, weil der Server vom Hersteller ist irgendwann offline. Und das garantieren sie dir natürlich. Na ja, wir sind garantiert immer verfügbar die nächsten 10 Jahre, aber so ein Haus, das halt effiziert sicher.
Das finde ich auch so. Es ist auch in einem anderen Kontext, das ist eine große Rolle bei Computerspielen, es ist ja auch so, dass es mittlerweile viele Sachen gibt, die nur noch über Server funktionieren. Und ich frage mich schon, ob man nicht politisch aktiv werden sollte und sagen sollte, Leute, wir brauchen eine Gesetzgebung, gesagt, alle Dinge, die auf einer Serververbindung aufgebaut sind und verkauft werden, müssen auch eine Lösung anbieten, dass ich das Ding zu Hause betreiben kann.
Du hast ja schon ganz oft allein so simple Dinge, wie auch wenn du alles lokal hast, du musst ja nur zum, ist das auch wirklich dein Dizentskey, dich einloggen und dann sitzt du im Flieger und willst eine Runde Duddle nebenher und dann hast du kein Internet und dann so, tschu, dann hast du jetzt halt 8 Stunden vor dir, wo du nicht zocken kannst.
Ich würde gerne noch eine letzte Alexa-Frage stellen und das ist die, dass ich glaube, ich werde sozusagen spätestens nächstes Jahr ernsthaft anfangen, ein bisschen drüber nachzudenken, wie ich das mache, wenn ich in eine Wohnung komme, wo eine Alexa steht. Weil ich tatsächlich finde es selber für mich persönlich unvertretbar. Also ich möchte bei mir nicht so eine Dinge in der Wohnung haben. So und ich finde das so unvertretbar, dass ich eigentlich auch nicht in eine Wohnung gehen möchte, wo sowas drin ist. Habt ihr für euch schon mal drüber nachgedacht und eine Entscheidung getroffen? Sowas wie, okay, ich besuche dich, aber dann musst du bitte dein Alexa irgendwie vom Strom trennen? Oder ist euch das egal? Oder sagt ihr, okay, naja, dann musst du das abfügen? Also im Montag hast du zuerst gemeldet.
Ich wollte eigentlich noch dazu was sagen. Wir hatten die Diskussion auch schon mal im Chaosradio mit diesen Fernsehern, wo in der Anleitung dann jetzt drin steht, bitte diskutieren Sie keine vertraulichen Dinge vor Ihrem Fernseher, weil wir machen da Gesprächserkennung. Das war so ein Smart TV. Und ja, klar, du müsstest im Prinzip den Leuten sagen, macht das Ding aus und macht auch euren Google Assistenten auf dem Telefon aus, wenn wir über irgendwas reden wollen, was halbwegs vertraulich sein soll. Aber im Prinzip müsstest du eben das vorher schon machen, um die Leute zu erziehen und das Bewusstsein zu bauen.
Nee, aber ich möchte von euch persönlich wissen, geht euch das auch so? Und wenn ja, habt ihr schon überlegt, wie ihr das macht?
Noch nicht überlegt, weil ich bisher niemanden kenne, der so ein Ding so Hause rumstehen hat.
Ich hatte jetzt schon mehrfach Leute, wo es so ein Ding rumsteht. Und dann spricht man halt nicht über gewisse Dinge. Und teilweise bin ich dann auch so konfrontiert, die halt da mitten sagt so, ja, lass uns das doch irgendwie im CCB bereden und nicht hier mit Alexa.
Und wie ist denn die Reaktion?
Na ja, dann teilweise so mit, oh, ach so, ja, stimmt. Und dann zieht man halt den Stecker. Also dann halt so, da die Leute sind so dran gewöhnt, dass halt diese Bequemlichkeit da ist mit Alexa, spiele hier in der Fische und dann kann man wunderschöne Musik hören und da sind sie so...
Wie schnell das auch geht.
Und dann sind die so schnell und dann weist man sie mal wieder drauf hin, dass es halt doch so ein Einschnitt ist und dass sie ja doch alles mithören. Also, oh, ja, stimmt, hast ja recht. Stecker gezogen.
Ich finde es schon krass, wie schnell das geht, weil, also, Alexa ist so richtig erst dieses Jahr losgegangen, oder? Ja. Als Produkt, das gab es schon länger, aber so richtig quasi, dass es also so funktioniert.
Das fing ja an mit Siri so ein bisschen und OK Google und wie es alles heißt. Und dann irgendwann so, naja, dann kann man es ja auch fest zu Hause hinstellen.
Ist das eigentlich OK Google Format C? Na, ist Festplatten gelöscht bei den Leuten, die zuhören?
Ruf uns an unter 0331 70 97 100, wenn gerade eure Festplatte gelöscht wird oder wenn ihr ein extra zu Hause stehen habt, weil mit so jemand würde ich eigentlich auch gerne mal reden, um es nachzufangen, weil letztlich kenne ich selber auch noch keinen. Ich gehe nur davon aus, dass mir es früher später beginnen wird.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, spiele Fritz, aber funktioniert so auch.
Sehr gut. Wir hören jetzt hier noch ein bisschen Musik von Ketzer. Wild Plains heißt der nächste Track. Danach Nachrichten, Wetter und Verkehr und danach sind wir wieder da.
Kommt endlich mal wieder in diese einzigartige Stadt. Da versprechen wir euch doch mal ein einzigartiges Konzert.
Jetzt präsentiert...
Montag, 5. März.
Bundespräsident Steinmeier versucht weiter, neue Wahlen zu verhindern und eine Regierungsbildung in Gang zu bringen. Am Abend hat er dazu die Chefs von CDU, CSU und SPD im Schloss Bellevue empfangen. Was genau besprochen wurde, ist nicht bekannt. Die Vorsitzenden wollen morgen erst ihre Parteikremien informieren. Ausminister Gabriel von der SPD sieht bei der Regierungsbildung keinen Zeitdruck. Niemand dürfe erwarten, dass das schnell gehe, hat er im ZDF gesagt. In der AfD bahnt sich möglicherweise ein neuer Machtkampf an. Nach ARD-Informationen denkt der AfD-Fraktionschef im Bundestag Gauland darüber nach, für den Parteivorsitz zu kandidieren. Damit könnte es auf dem Bundesparteitag an diesem Wochenende zu einer Kampfabstimmung kommen. Der Berliner Landeschef Basterski hat nämlich schon Anfang der Woche erklärt, dass er AfD-Chef werden will. Er gilt als Vertreter des gemäßigteren Flügels in der Partei. Der amtierende Parteichef Meuthen will ebenfalls wieder antreten. Die Berliner CDU wirft dem rot-rot-grünen Senat Versagen beim neuen Flughafen BER vor. Die letzten Berichte über Mängel und Risiken zeigten, dass der Senat seiner Verantwortung nicht gerecht werde, sagte CDU-Generalsekretär Evers im Abgeordnetenhaus. Auch Vertreter der Koalition äußerten sich in der Debatte besorgt, beim BER gibt es offenbar immer noch Probleme beim Brandschutz. Das steht in einem TÜV-Bericht, der vor kurzem bekannt geworden ist. Die Argentinische Marine stellt die Suche nach möglichen Überlebenden in einem verschollenen U-Boot ein. Es gehe nun nur noch darum, das Schiff zu finden und nicht mehr um die Rettung der Crew, sagte ein Sprecher der Marine. Der Kontakt zu dem U-Boot war am 15. November abgebrochen. 44 Besatzungsmitglieder waren an Bord. Mit den aktuellen Temperaturen in Berlin-Köpenick sind es Null und in Charlottenburg ein Grad. Neuglobse und Ludwigsfelde melden Null, Eberswalde und Forst ein Grad. Es ist noch meistens trocken und nur wenig bewölkt. Nach und nach kann es aber von Nordosten erste Schneeregen oder auch Schneeschauer geben. Passt dann bitte auf, da kann es glatt werden. Auf 0 bis minus 3 Grad gehen die Temperaturen im Laufe der Nacht runter. Morgen ist es meistens dicht bewölkt und von Nordosten ziehen immer wieder Schnee und Schneeregen durch. Am Nachmittag erreichen die Schauer dann auch den Flaming und die Niederlausitz. 1 bis 4 Grad sind an Höchsttemperaturen drin. Stadtverkehr Berlin in Weißensee ist die Buschallee zwischen Hansa-Straße und Suomonsstraße in Richtung Althohen Schönhausen gesperrt. Grund ist dann Wasserrohrbruch und zur S75. Wegen einer Weichenstörung kam im Ostbahnhof, fahren die Züge weiterhin nur zwischen Wartenberg und Ostkreuz. Da, wo es geht, euch eine gute Fahrt.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des AirBB.
Und wenn ihr einen ganz bestimmten Song aus der Fritz Playlist sucht, dann seht sie euch doch einfach an. Die Playlist auf fritz.de und in der Fritz App. Und das Auge hört mit, Mann.
Das Chaosradio hat noch eine halbe Stunde. Herzlich willkommen zurück, frabe Stanimon. Moin, Tagstar. Und wir sprechen hier über das Jahr 2017 und was so passiert ist. Und wir haben gerade über die ganzen Dinge gesprochen. Da nehm ich ganz kurz durch das Mikrofon. Sagt doch mal was. Hallo? Na siehst du, geht doch. Und wir haben ein sehr schönes Studio Message erhalten. Man muss davor, bevor ich die vorlese, noch kurz erklären, was Dash-Buttons sind. Amazon hat so Buttons, die kann man zu Hause installieren. Und wenn man die drückt, dann wird automatisch eine Kauf ausgelöst. Zum Beispiel, wenn man so die Idee ist, man klebt sich auf die Waschmaschine, wenn das Waschmittel alle ist, zack. Weil er schreibt jetzt, wenn er irgendwo einen Alexa sieht, dann setzt er Babyrassel und Penispumper auf die Einkaufsliste, Fram the Dash-Buttons drückt er aus Prinzip mehrmals. Dann noch schnell die Raumtemperatur auf 50 Grad gesetzt, die Jalousien auf Endlosschleife, Heavy Metal auf die Playlist für 6 Uhr morgens und den Nervenzusammenbruch des Hausbesitzers auf YouTube gestreamt. Ein gelungener Abend. Vielen Dank dafür, Ronje. Also vielleicht können wir doch ganz dankbar sein über die Technifizierung, zumindest fremder Haushalte, weil sie jede Menge Spaßpotenzial haben.
Das kommt drauf an, was dir an deinen Freunden liegt, ne?
Naja, wenn sie eine Alexa im Raum haben, geht es ja auch darum, sozusagen ein Statement abzugeben und wenn argumentative Argumente, die Argument enthalten, nicht helfen, dann vielleicht Heavy Metal X-O-Mogues.
Gibt es denn nicht so Alexa-Kondome?
So, so...
Naja, wahrscheinlich wird es schon irgendwann sein, dass sie auch Spracherkennung haben, dass dann nicht jeder irgendwie herkommen kann und sagen kann, Alexa. Apropos, das wollte ich noch fragen, Gesichtserkennung.
Ja, ganz große Mode.
Also die gibt es ja genau, die gibt es ja schon eine Weile, aber jetzt ist es wieder so eine, nachdem Apple das auch macht, sprechen jetzt auch mal alle drüber und die ich frage, ich frage nicht, warte, ne frage ich ob das ne ich frage, wann wird die kaputt gemacht? Ja. Also ist doch schon. Entschuldigung?
Also es gibt doch jetzt schon Masken.
War das nicht ein Fake oder haben die jetzt nur was ordentliches rausgebracht, wo man sah, dass es doch gar...
Das weiß man glaube ich noch nicht so ganz.
Also können wir nicht mal kurz anrufen?
Diese ganze Gesamte Gesichtserkennung hyped gerade irgendwie ganz heftig. Wir haben am Bahnhof Südkreuz Gesichtserkennung, um irgendwelche bösen Leute zu erkennen. In Apotheken wird es benutzt, um die Besucher nach Alter und Geschlecht zu... Bayer hat das gerade zurückziehen müssen, genauso wie es ja in Supermärkten versucht wurde. Es gibt so Werbetafeln und in der Werbetafel ist eine kleine Kamera, die filmt, wer vor der Werbetafel stehen bleibt.
In einer Apotheke?
Ja genau, das haben sie in Supermärkten versucht, da kam es nicht gut an und dann hat Bayer das in der Apotheke versucht, um rauszukriegen, wie alt sind die, in welches Geschlecht und was können wir da besser als Werbung machen. Wie lange gucken sich die Werbung überhaupt an?
Bitte guckt jetzt auf media.ccc.de, die Über-Tragung an Video Livestream und ihr seht mich jetzt an Facebook. Ja bitte, so in der Apotheke.
Das haben sie dann auch irgendwann eingesehen, dass das keine gute Idee war, aber wir haben das halt in Supermärkten, Apotheken, Bahnhöfen. Und in Australien gibt es jetzt ein Public-Private-Partnership, wo du, wenn du zum Beispiel Webseitenbetreiber bist und jetzt rauskriegen möchtest, ob der Mensch, der da vor der Webseite ist, wirklich derjenige ist, für den er sich ausgibt mit dem Account und so, kannst du ein Bild von der Person an diesen Dienst von der Regierung schicken, also das Bild mit den vermuteten Namen von den Menschen, den er eingegeben hat und die sagen dann, jo, der Name passt.
Weil die das von den biometrischen Fotos, die die mit dem Ausweis haben?
Genau.
Na gut, in Australien kannst du auch dein Nacktbild bei Facebook hochladen, damit sie dann zukünftig Nacktbilder von dir erkennen können.
Damit du Revenge-Porn verhinderst, schickst du Nacktbilder von dir an Facebook, damit sie daraus ein Hashbild, damit das nicht mehr anderes hochladen kann. Und, und, und, ein Mensch guckt sich das Bild an, um zu begutachten, ob es wirklich ein Nacktbild ist.
Gab es darüber Statistiken, wie viele Leute das gemacht haben auch wirklich?
Nee, das finde ich wirklich dramatisch.
Also ich finde es ja einerseits so krass, dass ein Konzern das macht. Aber ich würde gerne sehen, wie viele Leute das machen.
Ich frag mich, wie viele Bewerber sie bekommen haben.
Da fängt man glaube ich an einer Stelle an, sich über Menschen lustig zu machen, die nicht so okay sind. Weil ich finde das unfassbar in dieser Stelle, nur die Firma. Weil stell dir vor, du bist jemand, dem solche Fotos weggekommen sind. Und dann ist das deine nächste Möglichkeit. Du solltest es ja vorher da machen. Nein, darum geht es nicht. Es geht ja da wie vorher.
Du sollst die Bilder von dir da hinschicken, um zu verhindern, dass jemand sie veröffentlicht.
Ja, genau, aber niemand macht nackte Fotos, legt sie dann sofort raus. Die Idee ist ja dieses, ich habe jemanden im Verdacht, der wird das im nächsten tun, und dann macht man das. Das ist aus der Notlage diesen Impuls.
Ich kann die Verzweiflung und die Panik da sehr gut nachvollziehen, dass man dann alles versucht, um das zu verhindern.
Genau, und dann wird durch so ein Ding quasi so ein Vertrauen in diese Firma und die Technologie.
Das ist ekelhaft. Ich möchte mich wachen. Ich finde es krass, dass die Firma das Vertrauen missbraucht. Und wie es halt andererseits auch, wie man es davon ausgeht, dass Facebook nichts Böses will zum Beispiel. Und dass man da vor mehreren Jahren hat, dass man immer noch kritisch hinterfragt.
Die einzige Möglichkeit, sicher zu sein, ist sich noch mehr zu umblößen. Sehr schön. Da komme ich gleich zum nächsten Thema. Ich habe es nicht genau verstanden. Ich habe mir in die Vorbereitung der Datenreichtum reingeschrieben. Und jetzt denke ich bei allem von dem, was ihr jetzt schon in den letzten 90 Minuten kaputt gemacht habt, denke ich, der Datenreichtum ist böse. Aber das ist nicht ganz so.
Ich suche gerade die Notizen. Also Anlass war zum Beispiel, dass wir jetzt gerade wieder ein Datenreichtum hatten bei einem Fahrradverleihert, der auch in Berlin aktiv ist.
Was genau meinst du denn mit dem Begriff Datenreichtum?
Du meinst jemanden, der viel zu viele Daten sammelt, die man eigentlich nicht braucht und dann kommen sie platziert an.
Genau, so Gesichtserkennung, Vorratsleitspeicherung.
Also ganz kurz, der Begriff des Datenreichtums kommt daher, dass damals, ich glaube, es war sogar unsere Bundeskanzlerin vor nicht allzu langer Zeit mal gesagt hat, Daten sind das Gold des 21. Jahrhunderts. Man sollte doch Daten sammeln als etwas Positives sehen. Und in dem Zusammenhang wurde halt der Begriff Datenreichtum euphemistisch dafür verwendet, wenn immer einem Unternehmen Daten abhandengekommen sind und immer besonders auch dann, wenn man irgendwie sehen konnte, dass das vielleicht doch nicht so eine tolle Sache ist, dass diese Daten abhandengekommen sind.
Aber ist ja auch eigentlich auch geil, wenn man Datenreichtum sagt, kann man auch dieses Bild von dem Jolly Pirate, der sozusagen lustig, krakälend die Schatzkiste aus dem Ding rausträgt.
Ja und vor allem diese Datenschützer blockieren dann das mit diesem Reichtum, deswegen nerven die und müssen weg.
Okay, also es ist doch ein schlechtes Wort, also sozusagen ein Begriff, wo man sagt, da will man eigentlich wenige davon.
Ja, also Datenreichtum heißt halt, dass die Daten plötzlich öffentlich verfügbar sind, also zumindest in der Verwendung, wie wir das hier so machen.
Ich finde, wir sollten irgendwann noch mal eine Sendung machen, wo wir tatsächlich mal über die Chancen von Technik sprechen, weil das, also sagen, das macht ja schon Dinge auch möglich. Also ich mein, also ja, es ist gefällig, aber es macht, also das soll man vielleicht nicht vergessen, aber weil wir bald schon wieder am Ende sind, wir wollten ja noch über was anderes reden, was in Zukunft ansteht.
Du meinst diesen Kongress, diesen Chaos Communication Kongress.
Also ich will vorher noch mal fragen, so das Jahr 2007 zusammengefasst, würde man das noch mal so wollen oder was wünschen für das nächste Jahr?
Ich würde die Simulation gerne beim letzten Safe Point noch mal starten.
Wann ist der?
Vor Trump.
Also ich glaube, wir waren uns vor der Sendung ganz einig, dass diese Theorie, dass wir alle in einem absurden Universum, das gerade noch übrig geblieben ist, nachdem irgendein Unfall am NLC passiert ist und dass wir gerne irgendwie zurück wollten zu diesem Punkt, bevor dieser Unfall passiert ist und uns dann ein Universum suchen, in dem diese ganze kaputte Sachen nicht passiert sind. Das hätten wir gerne.
Können wir es einfach nicht schlimmer machen?
Schlimmer geht immer.
Danke.
Fakt doch sowas nicht.
Nicht lächelt und war froh und es kam schlimmer.
Aber immerhin, bevor die Welt untergeht, gibt es mal Chaos Communication Congress. Also hoffen wir alle, dass es noch so lange hält. Ist nur ein Monat, aber man weiß ja nie.
Ein Kongresszentrum haben wir schon ruiniert.
Das ist ja Hamburg. Genau, ich wollte gerade sagen, der ist ja in Leipzig.
Genau.
Die wichtigste Frage, die jede Hörerin, jede Hörer sofort hat, wenn es um den Chaos Communication Congress geht, ist gibt es noch Tickets?
Nein?
Nein. Keine Tickets mehr?
Ja.
Aber war nicht erst eine Tickets verkaufswelle?
Nein. Alle drei sind durch, alle Tickets sind weg und es gibt aber noch auf events.ccc.de im Wiki, wenn ihr euch da ein bisschen durchklickt, da gibt es eine Ticketbörse. Die Idee ist, dass da auch so ein bisschen drauf geguckt wird, dass jetzt niemand anfängt, da den Wucher aufzurufen, sondern dass wirklich Leute, die merken, oh, keine Ahnung, vielleicht sollte ich doch lieber bei der Abtante vorbeischauen bei Weihnachten, anstatt auf diesen Kongress zu gehen, dann ihr Ticket abgeben und dass man dann vielleicht noch eine Möglichkeit hat, Tickets, die ja meistens dann auch mit Hotelbuchungen einhergehen, zu erwerben und dann vielleicht doch noch auf diesen Kongress zu kommen.
Jetzt ist ja heute das Engelsystem, das sogenannte online gegangen und Engel sind ja die Helfer, die auf dem Kongress mithelfen. Es ist aber nicht so, wenn man sich da eintritt, kann man nach Hause machen, die Chance zu kommen, sondern das sind auch Leute, die ihr schon ein Ticket haben.
Ja, genau. Also das kann man auch nur jedem empfehlen, der auf dem Kongress ist. Wenn ihr nicht einfach nur Vorträge hören wollt, das könnt ihr nämlich auch irgendwie von zu Hause, vom Bildschirm, macht mal eine Engelschicht, probiert mal aus. Ihr trefft eine Menge interessante Leute und lernt eine Menge.
Vor allem sieht man Seiten vom Kongress, die man eigentlich nie sehen kann. Damit erlebt man den Kongress erst richtig, weil es ja entsteht ja nur darauf, dass ganz viele Leute mit anpacken und das macht richtig geistig.
Und man konsumiert eben nicht nur, sondern wird selber aktiv und ansonsten Chaos-Party-innen und Chaos-Party-innen.
Genau, das auch.
Das sind die Menschen, die Menschen an die Hand nehmen, die zum ersten Mal auf den Kongress sind.
Genau, wenn es dein erster Kongress ist, und du nicht unsicher bist oder irgendwo einfach nur Leute kennenlernen willst, mit denen du halt über den Kongress ziehen kannst, dann ist das eine gute Anlaufstelle, wenn es dann erst mal beim Kongress ist.
Wie ist es denn bei euch? Was macht ihr denn? Welche hälfte Funktion macht ihr denn auf dem Kongress?
Mal gucken.
Internet.
Und ich werde wieder mithelfen, dass ihr alle zu Hause bleiben könnt und Videos gucken könnt.
Ich bringe ihm dann immer wieder was ans Mischpult.
Auch das muss erledigt werden. Wird es, weil wir hier im Radio sind, eine Podcastbühne geben, wie es die Jahre davor gab?
Dieses Jahr ja nicht, es wird aber voraussichtlich eine Podcast Assembly geben, das heißt zumindest Audio wird es sehr wahrscheinlich in irgendeiner Form geben.
Okay, aber nicht quasi diesen eigenen Raum, wo man mit Publikum Dinge tun kann?
Nee, wahrscheinlich nicht. Und deswegen ist das wahrscheinlich dieses Jahr auch unser letztes Chaosradio. Richtig?
Wie für immer?
Nein, dieses Jahr.
Okay, gut, also falls es ein Sendungszentrum geben wird, gäbe es unter Umständen noch ein Chaosradio. Aber okay, kommen wir zum Vortragsprogramm. Ich habe, es gibt ja dieses Halfnab, das ist auch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, da könnt ihr auch mithelfen. Es gibt eine Vorabwesung des Vortragsprogramms online, das heißt Halfnab und da stehen nicht drin, wann die Vorträge laufen, sondern da steht drin, welche Vorträge es gibt. Und dann könnt ihr anklicken, was euch interessiert und daraus wird dann der Zeitplan gebastelt mit der Hoffnung, dass dann möglichst wenige Vorträge, die dieselben Leute interessieren, parallel laufen. Also dass selten vorkommt, dass ihr der Vorsitzende sagt, oh nein, meine beiden allergeilsten Vorträge laufen parallel, dass das nicht passiert, das könnt ihr helfen, indem ihr jetzt dahin geht und das schon mal ausfüllt. Ich habe da schon mal reingeguckt und habe einen Vortrag gesehen, der mich sehr interessiert hat. Und zwar da geht es darum, dass wir die Digitalisierung anbeten wie etwas göttliches. Gefällt mir alleine schon das Bild, mit dem Computer umzugehen wie mit einem Gott oder will denn jemand drüber sprechen, dass er sagt, naja, also momentan schreiben wir dem Digitalen so eine allmächtige Omnipotenz zu, dass wir alle Probleme lassen, sich damit lösen und der will mal sagen, was denn wirklich jetzt der Stande sind, wo man vielleicht damit leben kann und vielleicht wo es nichts bringt.
Das hatten wir schon mal unter dem Begriff Elektronenhirn. Da gab es das schon mal, dass man sagt, das wird dann alles besser und dann fliegen wir zum Mars.
Naja, aber ich glaube, das haben wir Socialbots. Also Elektronen ist ja sozusagen, na gut, wir werden sehen, was ist, was findet ihr im Programm interessant? Was hat euch da sozusagen, was sind eure Highlights? Was wollt ihr hier schon mal zum Besten geben?
Na, zum einen ganz kurz, wir hatten ja vorhin über diese Mikrofone gesprochen im Kabel. Da geht es einen Vortrag zu über versteckte Überwachungstechnologie. Und ansonsten finde ich mal ganz spannend, so ein bisschen zu gucken, wie war das eigentlich, bevor ich im Internet war? Es gibt da irgendwie Vorträge zu BBSen, also das heißt zu Mailbox-Systemen. Das war zum Beispiel lange vor meiner Zeit. Dann natürlich wieder Security Nightmares.
Ich habe mir so einen Vortrag rausgesucht, der heißt Null und Einsen auf dem Acker. Und da geht es tatsächlich darum, wie diese Digitalisierung Einzug in die Agrarwirtschaft nimmt. Und das finde ich, ist eigentlich sowas, was man partout nicht auf dem Schirm hat. Aber ich finde, das klingt erst mal total interessant.
Das stimmt, das habe ich auch gesehen. Das ist ja wirklich so, also das ist ja etwas, was man, die es nicht auf dem Schirm haben. Und da ist ja autonomes Fahren schon.
Ja, ich habe es schon mal am Augenwinkel aufgenommen, aber das ist dann so. Aber das halt mal von jemandem, der wirklich tief drin steckt zu hören, klingt glaube ich sehr spannend, weil irgendwie, ja, man hat schon so ein ziemlich aufgebautes Navi in so einem Traktor drin, dass der eigentlich fast autonom fährt, also nur jemand Gas geben muss, damit er rollt.
Genau, das Problem ist, dass sie Karten dazu brauchen, wo alle Strommasten zum Beispiel drauf sind, die in ihrem Feld stecken. Und es gab wohl mal ein Inzident, dass dann so ein Trecker so eine Strommast umgefahren hat. Seitdem dürfen sie nicht mehr komplett autonom.
Und ich glaube, da wird man dann im Vortrag drüber hören oder nicht spoilern.
Genau, das hat mir ein Landwirt vor ein paar Jahren erzählt.
Ich frage mich auch, ob wir noch was dazu hören würden, was auch dieses Jahr, so können wir im Rückblick noch sagen, herumging, ist, dass es im Agrarmarkt einen reichhaltigen Schwarzmarkt gibt für Hacking-Tools für Ersatzteile.
Das hatte ich auch gelesen.
Weil Ersatzteile, die in Trecker eingebaut sind, werden sozusagen über einen Computer lizensiert und dann macht man das so als Ersatzteil.
Da war dann noch der Haken, dass man die passenden Ersatzteile nicht mal wirklich schnell genug hinbekommt, weil das dann irgendwie eine Farm mitten in Amerika ist, wo man jetzt nicht so schnell mal eben von aus Deutschland oder so was, oder England, passende Ersatzteile mit Techniker hinbekommt und dann gab es da einen Schwarzmarkt wohl, wo man dann doch mal innerhalb von ein paar Stunden das passende Ding hinbekommt, aber...
Landwirte sind halt gewohnt, ihre Maschinen selbst zu reparieren und die Hersteller möchten natürlich da jetzt ein Geschäft draus machen.
Aber vielleicht werden dann Landwirte irgendwann die besseren Programmierer, weil sie sozusagen so trainiert darin sind.
Auf jeden Fall werden sie trainiert.
Oder sind die Leute, die uns in der Revolution helfen, weil sie wiederum die Technik überall drin überlisten können.
Die einzigen, die Killer-Roboter überwachen können.
Abschalten. Aber was gibt's noch? Was ich ganz spannend finde, wir haben dieses Jahr das erste Mal einen kompletten Track der sich mit Resilienz beschäftigt, also mit Widerstandsfähigkeit. Wie widerstandsfähig ist Software, wie widerstandsfähig ist Hardware? Und wie kann man widerstandsfähige Hardware produzieren, die gegen gewisse Fehler nicht anfällig ist, die direkt so designt ist, dass man nicht sagt, ach ich kloppe da mal ein Programm hin und das wird schon irgendwie laufen, sondern dass man sich von Anfang an mal überlegt, wie programmiere ich das denn? Und welche technischen Ansätze wähle ich, dass möglichst wenig Fehler passieren? Und dann gibt es andere Vorträge, die überlegen sich, okay, ich kann zwar irgendwie sogar mathematisch beweisen, dass ein Programm genau das tut, was es tun soll, nur gehe ich denn von den richtigen Annahmen aus, wenn ich diese mathematischen Beweise aufstelle? Das ist also ein wirklich komplexes Feld, aber eins, das bisher viel zu wenig beleuchtet ist und das wirklich dazu führen könnte, dass wenn man da wirklich mal eine Debatte.
Ich muss dich kurz umbringen, du hast Montags erzählt, es gibt eine Art Dinge zu hacken, die man immer in einem Hollywood-Film sieht, wo man denkt, so ein Quatsch, die jetzt aber echt ist.
Naja, wir hatten in den letzten Jahren eine ganze Reihe Sicherheitslücken, die sich zum Beispiel auf WLAN und Bluetooth bezogen, aber eben nicht auf die Software, die auf dem Handy läuft, sondern auf die Software, die in den Chips läuft, die in den Handys eingebaut sind. Das heißt, ich habe Bluetooth aktiviert auf meinem Handy und im Vorbeigehen kann jemand den Bluetooth-Chip in meinem Handy umprogrammieren und damit Code auf meinem Handy ausführt und Sicherheitslücken im Handy auslösen.
Wie wir jetzt im Vorbeigehen?
Also per Funk, drahtlos.
Naja, beim Vorbeigehen auch, was die Zeitspanne angeht, also so innerhalb weniger Sekunden oder?
Ja, man kann ja mal daneben stehen für ein paar Sekunden, aber schon.
U-Bahn reicht ja auch.
U-Bahn reicht. Also solange irgendwie ich stehe mit jemandem für eine Station in der U-Bahn, ein glaubhaftes Eingriffsszenario und Bluetooth funktioniert jetzt nicht nur, wenn ich, wenn ich Körper an Körper mit jemandem stehe, sondern es reicht jetzt, dass ich wegen demselben Waggon bin. Und das, also man muss sich das halt im Klaren machen. Es geht nicht unbedingt darum, dass man mit dem Menschen jetzt wirklich dicht an dicht stehen muss. Das ist gar nicht notwendig.
Gibt es auch Bluetooth-Kondome? Oh Gott, dass ich überhaupt noch technische Geräte benutze und ich mittlerweile angefangen hab.
Oh, im IRC kommt auch gerade IME. Es gab ja auch die Intel Management Engine, die in modernen Notebooks zum Beispiel drin ist, wo man dann per Netzwerk auf einen Management Prozessor zugreifen kann, der im Notebook eingebaut ist und der auch läuft, wenn das Notebook sonst aus ist.
Ja, also du hast...
Warte mal, mein Notebook hat eine Komponente, die an ist, wenn es aus ist?
Ja.
Du willst ja das BIOS updaten können, wenn das Ding aus ist in der Firma.
Oder du möchtest als Systemadministrator von all deinen Schäfchen auf den Rechner und irgendwie Windows updaten können und tralala. Und irgendwie Remote Services, wenn der sein Rechner ganz doll verfickelt hat.
Da war auch eine Sicherheitszocke drin oder was?
Genau. Und zwar das Ding, diese Software darf alles. Stell dir vor, du hast ein Stück Software, das läuft aus einem Betriebssystem. Das Betriebssystem darf im Prinzip schon alles. Dieses Betriebssystem ist im Chip und darf noch mal mehr. Und das läuft und hört auf den Netzwerkport und viel Spaß.
Okay, möchten wir dann ganz zum Schluss noch mal über das sprechen, was alle gesprochen haben, über Apple?
Ja, Apple schickt sich gerade an. Apple schickt sich gerade an, so richtig das zu werden, was Microsoft mal vor so 10, 15 Jahren war. Nämlich eine Sicherheitslücke nach der anderen.
Eine wird besser als die andere.
Eine besser als die andere. Und kein richtig geschicktes Händchen dabei, wie sie diese Probleme handhaben. Oder wie sie generell mit Sicherheitslücken umgehen.
Jetzt sagt noch schnell, die Sicherheitslücke, die Sendung ist gleich vorbei.
Ohne Passwort als Superadministrator anmelden.
Das ist so großartig. Probiert das mal. Wenn ihr den aktuellen Mac habt, wo das neueste Betriebssystem drauf ist, heißt das Mac OS. Probiert mal, in die Systemeinstellung zu gehen und dort auf eine Einstellung, wo ihr euch extra anmelden müsst, klickt auf das Schloss und dann steht da voreingetragen euer Username. Dann tragt ihr oben, löscht den, tragt dort root ein, R-O-O-T, drückt einfach Enter ohne ein Passwort einzugeben.
Und dann noch mal Enter.
Wenn das nicht funktioniert, noch ein paar Mal. Dann seid ihr irgendwann eingeloggt und dieses root, das ist Gott. Also Film Computer ist root Gott.
Und das ist alles.
Das ist unfassbar.
Ein imaginäres Wesen.
Es war ein schönes 2017. Ich danke euch, dass ihr hier wart.
Gerne.
Ich muss mein Apple Computer noch updaten.
Oder zumindest ein Passwort setzen.
Oder ein Passwort setzen. Wir hören uns dann im nächsten Jahr wieder, vermutlich. Hoffen wir. Wenn wir nicht expositiv bis dahin.
Und dann wieder hier.
Und dann wieder hier. Die Sendung gibt es auf chaosradio.ccc.de. Und ihr findet dann auch alle Links zu den Dingen, die ihr erwähnt habt, dort in den Show Notes. Ihr könnt die Sendung auch nochmal hören oder nochmal angucken. Und mir bleibt dieses Jahr an dieser Stelle in dieser Sendung noch einzusagen. Mein Name ist Markus Richter. Und ich möchte, dass ihr euch nicht überwachen lasst. Und immer schön eure Backups verschüsselt. Tschüss.
Tschüss.
And how many 40s they smoke.